Ross, take it away.
This is your story.
Well, I'm a big football fan.
Are you a fan of it?
Oh my God.
This is all I do.
I'm gonna be in mourning after Sunday
when I don't have football until next August,
it's gonna be hard for me.
Who's your team?
You know what?
I'll be happy either way.
'Cause I went to university of Georgia.
Matt Stafford, quarterback for the Rams is a Georgia guy.
So he's a Bulldog.
So I gotta be happy for him,
but it's been so long for Cincinnati.
If they win, that would be amazing.
So I'm good either way.
See, well that's great.
So, you're gonna be happy on Sunday, no matter what.
No matter what, as long as I get to eat food, I'm good.
Exactly.
And you know, last year, how about this?
An estimated 16.1 million Americans
planned to skip work the day after the Super Bowl.
Maybe they're eating, maybe be their drinking,
or they're just partying.
And so USA Today reports,
a high school student named Frank Rugieri
says he has a solution for all that lost productivity.
How about this, move the Super Bowl to Saturday.
Hello?
Brilliant.
And he started a petition online.
It already has 120,000 signatures.
I actually went on and signed it myself.
Oh good for you.
Yeah, hello, right?
We're all home.
We wanna watch on Saturday and then recover.
Let the bloat come down from the hot wings on Sunday.
The NFL, they may even get some more ratings, you know?
And kids could watch,
and not have to worry about school the next day.
So, I'm wondering, will you guys sign this petition?
I don't sign petitions, but I totally endorse this.
I think it's a brilliant idea because...
it just, you're, it just, it makes so much sense.
Why wouldn't you?
Exactly.
And the Super Bowl, I'm sure there are people
who wanna travel to go to the game, but have work on Monday.
It's true, I'm sure some people
are not feeling great the next day,
'cause they had the best time ever as they should.
And it's late, the game goes really late.
Really late.
And if your team wins you're celebrating,
and if your team loses you're...
Yeah, no, either way you should.,,
You're nursing it.
You're nursing it, yeah.
Have a bender and a night of it.
And I just think, you know, maybe,
'cause it's Super Bowl Sunday, it all the S's,
well, Super Bowl Saturday, is still a very Sy thing.
You know the reason they do it?
They protected college football and high school football.
They set it up that the NFL would play on Sundays,
so that the college games and the high school games
wouldn't have competition,
but there is no other football game on Super Bowl Sunday.
They can make one exception for Super Bowl Sunday
and move it to Saturday.
I'm you got my vote, kid, that's what you got.
Little Frank has fixed it.
All right, and it's your story.
All right, and this one is,
I think probably everybody knows,
last week there was a big party in the UK
when Queen Elizabeth became the first British Monarch
to celebrate her Platinum Jubilee.
That's 70 years as queen, which is amazing.
Phenomenal, yeah.
It is great, but here's the deal.
It begins a year long Jubilee, a year long celebration,
but there's just one little hitch.
Take a look at the souvenirs that were printed.
Now, if you look at this, it's the Queen's Jubilee,
but there was a little problem.
Can we zoom in on this and show them that instead
of the word Jubilee, it says jubbly.
Now, I play Words With Friends, and that is not a word.
You do not get any points for jubbly.
So, good news is for collectors,
this stuff is now worth a fortune, but somebody, you know,
back in the old day off with their heads,
send them to the Tower.
I just hear the queen say it like, jubbly, it's my jubbly.
But the jubbly, what is jubbly?
Isn't it a saying over there?
I don't think so.
It's a bit jubbly.
I think that describes the, you know,
when I haven't been working out, it's a bit jubbly.
That's me after Super Bowl Sunday.
I'm a little jubbly up here, yeah.
All right, next up, a new poll just asked 2000 Americans
an impossible question.
What is the best TV show ever?
Ross, Deborah, can you pick what one?
I have no idea what one.
I mean, if I were voting, you know, childhood Ross
wants Jem and the Holograms or Saved by the Bell to win.
But I would, I don't, I mean,
Sex in the City would be my vote now.
Oh, that's a good one.
Right?
What would be your vote?
I don't know, I'd be thinking like a cartoon or something
but I'm sure that's not the right answer.
So, I'm gonna pass.
What would yours be if you got to say what,
like, your favorite?
I loved Petticoat Junction when I was a kid,
and don't ask me why.
And I love the other one with Eva Gabor, Green Acres.
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
I just thought, you know,
how did she have those beautiful outfits living in a shack?
I didn't understand that.
What would yours be?
I don't know why I immediately went to like Cheers.
Oh, that was a good one, yeah.
I'm binging that right now on Hulu by the way,
from beginning.
Oh gosh, it, there's...
Shelley Long, Ted Danson.
And the episode where she leaves
is just one of my favorite, most haunted-
So, maybe that's the answer.
Well, it, the Daily News reports
that the number one rated show was Friends.
Oh, okay, I get that.
And then this is shocking because of course
Seinfeld, that could have easily taken the top spot,
but that came in a close second followed by Game of Thrones.
Yes.
Then Three's Company.
Oh, really?
And then Frazier.
And the Simpsons made the top 10
coming in at number nine and Sopranos at 13, hmm.
Doh!
I don't know about Sopranos at 13?
Yeah, should be a little higher.
I also like the West Wing too.
That's such a great show, right?
Mad Men.
Mad Men could be up there.
There's so many good shows, that's the point.
I loved 24.
Oh!
Oh, that was a great show!
Oh my God, 24 was incredible.
We had a rule in the studio,
if you hadn't seen it within the second day, too bad.
We're talking about it.
It's on you.
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah, you gotta watch it.
I love it.
Well, I love these debates and I love television
and guess what?
We get to come back and do more of it.
We'll be right back.
(audience cheering)
(cheerful music)